I think the future of South Africa
really at this point is is unwritten in
a different way to in the past we had
very established dynamics in the past
with the ANC as the liberation movement
that successfully and rightly one their
1994 election it was a tremendous moment
I was there at the Union Buildings when
nelson mandela was inaugurated and the
jets flew over trailing the new South
African flag and all of us who were
there basically hit the ground because
we thought we were being attacked and
suddenly realized no those are our Jets
so I've been there at that moment I've
been there in the moment we're thabo
mbeki stood up and said you know he was
the next generation and bliss was it in
the stone to be alive but to be young
was to be magical you know the the
quoting Shelley so I've been there at
those moments I've been there at the
1999 election when Mandela handed over
power an African head of state of the
the most powerful country in the
continent handing over power to the next
generation I've been there at a time
where Thabo Mbeki's bizarre approach to
AIDS had severe consequences but also
where his remarkable economic
stewardship helped transform the country
so there really is a mixed legacy there
and people shouldn't lose sight of that
we did go to very significant growth a
real Asian African lion to match the
Asian Tigers and that was tab on Becky
can claim a lot of credit for that so
there is this terribly mixed legacy
there but the Jacob Zuma saga has left
has kept the country going back and
forth for the last two years absolutely
riveted and we haven't known how this
would pan out and now at least the
landscape is a lot clearer he is
president there is a quite strong
opposition the Democratic Alliance which
actually controls one province now a
very important province that holds Cape
Town there is a
a second party that has grown up in
opposition that consists of former
liberation movement leaders who that got
eight percent of the vote it's not a
huge showing but they are a truly
multiracial party and it's quite
possible that they're holding is going
to increase in the future and they
actually are the official opposition in
several provinces so you do see at both
the provincial level and at the the
state level a very significant
transformation of the landscape there is
an increasingly strong opposition that
may get stronger in future the ANC did
not quite get to its two-thirds majority
and it's not clear whether it will again
so you may be moving towards a two or
three party system that is more
multiracial and that has a balance of
powers at the regional level that looks
very much like many many successful
democracies so that's tremendously
exciting Jacob Zuma people have very
diverse views on him certainly he's a
tremendously talented man who's
incredibly savvy who's self-taught and
who has shown tremendous resilience he
has also taken some said some very
bizarre things about hiv/aids which is
the last thing we need in the country
and he has a there is sometimes I'm all
for inclusiveness but there is sometimes
a dangerous populism that creeps in
there and we'll have to see i believe we
have to give new presidents the benefit
of the doubt in some way we have to
vigorously hold them accountable as the
media and as civil society as well as
the opposition holding them accountable
but I believe you also have to give
people a chance to prove themselves and
if he adopts policies that are forward
thinking if he grows the country if he's
inclusive I believe that there is the
potential to have a country that can
continue to be a light to all nations as
South Africa in so many respects has
been and shown to the world
you